avete parlato di recente con
un adolescente
Essendo già lì oppure oppure ne avete
sentito parlare magari perché spesso
sono
ci sono articoli sui giornali che
parlano di loro
io sono una di quelle che vengono
definite osservatrice privilegiata
perché oltre ad essere da oltre
vent'anni una psicologa che si occupa di
adolescenti anche di adulti ma
prevalentemente di ragazzi e giovani
sono anche mamma di due adolescenti e di
uno che presto diventerà tale e ho le
prove
Ma quando si sente parlare di
adolescenti in genere abbiamo tutti dei
preconcetti
è come se ci aspettassimo dei mostri a
tre teste succede così io ho un bambino
carino coccoloso che poi cresce arriva
intorno alla fine della scuola primaria
8 9 10 anni
è un po' più difficile da gestire e poi
Boom
adolescenti basta impossibile non si può
più parlare non si può fare
nulla che sia
uno scambio umano simpatico
e allora bisogna chiederci Ma perché
sono davvero solo gli ormoni che li
trasformano oppure succede qualcos'altro
dentro di loro
Io mi sono convinta che
gli adolescenti siano sottoposti ad una
setta pace di macchina del tempo
hanno la necessità
di ritornare a schemi infantili ma
proprio della primissima infanzia e
succede questa cosa avete presente
quando i bimbi proprio piccoli
cominciano a camminare
succede quel processo che viene chiamato
allontanamento avvicinamento I bimbi
fanno i primi passi da soli si
allontanano dalla mamma dai genitori ma
poi hanno l'esigenza assoluta di
ritornare dalla mamma per ricordarsi che
qualcuno c'è che li sostiene oppure ci
sono quei bimbi che camminando tendono
la manina e non la vogliono mollare
e la mamma in genere o chiunque di che
stia facendo camminare è lì è pronta ad
accoglierli è pronta a sostenere tutti
questi passi Incerti succede un'altra
cosa ancora prima che ha a che vedere
con la comunicazione
e sia una un atteggiamento estremamente
disponibile nei confronti di questi
bimbi quando i bambini cominciano a
parlare
immaginatevi intorno all'anno di vita 12
13 mesi le prime parole le prime Proto
parole che nessuno riconosce se non i
genitori e chi si occupa di questi bimbi
Io per esempio quando ero piccola
piccola
per dire la parola sapone dicevo
pognogno
adesso non giudicatemi non so da dove
venisse la parola cognomi ho fatto sta
che mia mamma sapeva che quando io
chiedevo il pognogno Volevo il sapone da
annusare la saponetta Quella quella
vecchia
e nel momento in cui lei mi diceva
sapone mi restituiva la realtà mi dava
un frammento di realtà che io altrimenti
non sarei stata in grado di
nominare e ancora prima quando i bimbi
sono in braccio alla mamma le mamme di
solito
se li siedono qui Avete presente su
l'anca sul bacino perché devono avere
l'altra mano libera per fare le cose
i bimbi Quando sono in braccio con la
manina di solito indicano mostrano e di
solito Chi ha in braccio il bimbo nomina
le parole al posto del bambino quindi
palla sole cuore amore eccetera e questo
processo in gergo tecnico si chiama
ostensione
io mostro al bambino il mondo glielo
spiego e questo processo in realtà va
avanti diversi anni quando poi ci sono
le generalizzazioni dei verbi quando ci
sono le correzioni verbali congiuntivi
tutto quello che è dialogo tutto quello
che è comunicazione
io ai bambini lo spiego
ed ho pazienza
ho tanta pazienza perché
da un genitore con un bambino piccolo ci
si aspetta che sia paziente
perché so che tutto quello che questo
bimbo sta facendo è fondamentale per il
suo sviluppo so che sta mettendo le basi
per riuscire a crescere a diventare una
persona migliore
con gli adolescenti no
No io la pazienza non ce l'ho più non la
metto più Perché a un certo punto Esiste
un momento tangibile che sia 5 6 7 8 9
10 anni in cui dico a questo bambino sei
grande Sei grande Cosa vuol dire che
questo bimbo è grande che mi aspetto da
lui che si comporti in modo responsabile
Certo
rispetto all'età responsabile rispetto
all'età però generalmente essere grandi
significa riordinare la stanza occuparsi
del fratellino
fare i compiti farsi lo zaino da solo
e siamo arrivati all'età delle medie
con questo Sei grande però io ho
una contropartita cioè
il ragazzino vuole essere trattato da
grande Quindi tu mi chiedi dei doveri
Dammi anche dei Benefit del mio essere
grande e l'essere grande Che cosa
significa faccio quello che voglio ovvio
no Quindi non voglio limitazioni con il
telefono non voglio discussioni
sull'orario di ritorno Dove sei Cosa fai
esco
e questo genera incomprensioni
e sono delle incomprensioni che a volte
diventano veramente
difficili da gestire ci sono famiglie
che
subiscono pesantemente la fase
adolescenziale dei figli e non solo ci
sono anche classi situazioni scolastiche
in cui gli adolescenti sono difficili da
gestire perché sembra come
se la comunicazione non funzionasse più
io parlo in un modo e i ragazzi parlano
in un altro
però la comunicazione è la chiave di
tutto
Io ho bisogno una necessità impellente
di trovare un dialogo che sia un dialogo
efficace un dialogo efficiente per cui
io genitore adulto ma anche coach
educatore insegnante Chiunque abbia a
che fare con questi ragazzi deve trovare
il modo per comunicare con loro non
stiamo facendo generializzazioni non è
così semplice però dal mio osservatorio
privilegiato purtroppo Vedo delle
situazioni di grande criticità di grande
fragilità e quindi credo che sia
assolutamente necessario fondamentale
provare a tradurre
Mi immagino questi ragazzi come degli
esoscheletri Avete presente i
Transformers che c'è l'omino piccolo con
tutto sto coso intorno
per cui loro girano nel mondo con questi
esoscheletri e si muovono e hanno anche
una certa Mole quando si muovono fanno
rumore
chiunque sia entrato abbia avuto a che
fare con una classe o con un gruppo di
adolescenti sa che fanno rumore
In genere si fanno anche sentire perché
li trasformer c'è il megafono Avete
presente l'omino
e in questo
nascondersi dietro l'esoscheletro ci
sono delle anime fragili non sono tutte
fragili alla stessa maniera Ma spesso
sono fragili in modo diverso
Quindi quello che è importante che noi
facciamo è di insegnare a questi ragazzi
a trasmettere le loro emozioni in modo
editabile cioè spiegatemi Di che cosa
avete bisogno e io provo a venirmi
incontro
all'interno resta la fragilità che deve
trovare un modo di uscire
e il compito di noi adulti è quello di
facilitare questa uscita perché lo
sappiamo non fa bene tenere le cose
dentro ma noi adulti non è che siamo più
bravi anche abbiamo le stesse identiche
difficoltà solo che i nostri
esoscheletri sono
in genere meno rumorosi Impariamo ad
essere meno rumorosi e meno ingombranti
e andiamo avanti nel mondo senza
traduttore
parte di questo esoscheletro è anche
la necessità di appartenenza
lo state leggendo tutti con
l'internazione giusta Giusto giusto non
mi ha
abbiamo reso tutti quest'estate con la
pubblicità che è stata fatta alla
parlata in corsivo
e questo è un modo che fa molto ridere i
ragazzi quando lo facciamo noi adulti
perché non lo facciamo mai in maniera
corretta chiaramente Ma hanno necessità
questi ragazzi di
slang di
outfit sentite come sono moderna perché
devono mostrare di far parte di qualche
cosa che va oltre la loro fragilità
la caratteristica però è che noi non
dobbiamo fermarci a quello che vediamo
dobbiamo farci strada in mezzo ai nostri
Transformer e trovare quello che sta
dietro quindi anche se ci sono queste
cose buffe le parlate
termini mai sentiti mai visti che io
continuo ad arrancare per cercare di
comprendere di tradurre dietro a tutto
questo in realtà ci sono dei pensieri e
delle emozioni fluide
i ragazzi però
odiano e detestano essere chiusi con i
loro pensieri nelle scatoline che invece
fanno parte della nostra mente di adulto
Tenete conto che il cervello dei
ragazzini termina di
costruire le sue connessioni cerebrali
intorno ai 12 13 anni
Però noi ci aspettiamo che siano molto
più efficienti che siano molto più
veloci rapidi risolutori di problemi
molto prima quando loro cervello è
ancora in formazione noi adulti D'altro
canto
funzioniamo per l'80% della nostra vita
attraverso
gli script l'adattamento di scritta gli
script sono delle modalità per cui se io
entro in una stanza per esempio il mio
scritto mi dice entri in salute ti
presenti Dai la mano
e questo era solo uno degli script gli
adolescenti hanno necessità
di uscire dalle scatoline hanno
necessità di diventare qualche cosa di
fluente di fluido qualche cosa che
scivola che si adatta ai luoghi in cui è
di Esplora e poi ritorna Io credo che la
bellezza del pensiero degli adolescenti
sia qualcosa di straordinario Ma devi
riuscire ad arrivarci dentro
quando io vi dico fluido la parola
fluido poi per esempio
potete pensare ad un'altra cosa
estremamente di moda fra i ragazzi che è
il gender Fluid la fluidità di genere ne
avrete senz'altro sentito parlare Che
cosa significa che cos'è perché anche
sul genere sessuale questi ragazzi hanno
necessità di essere fluidi
perché non vogliono essere definiti Che
cosa significa significa che
lo leggete non lui non lei semplicemente
Io semplicemente me stesso
e gender Fluid è un fenomeno in
grandissimo momento qui in Italia ma non
è una moda non una moda nella quale
possiamo inserire
un'abitudine leggera è un inquietudine
profonda perché io non so come mi sento
e se ci pensate se noi adulti li
pensiamo a come ci siamo sentiti ad
essere adolescenti non è così lontano
dal sentire che abbiamo provato anche
noi semplicemente non gli avevamo dato
un nome semplicemente
per noi era più
facile dare meno nomi alle cose
al di là di tutto questo ci sono dei
tentativi a volte maldestri di dare una
coscienza di se stessi di dare una
definizione del sé e noi dobbiamo
cercare di assecondarla questa cosa
perché davvero è cosa rara riuscire a
scoprire quello che sta dietro
dentro a questi esoscheletri ci sono
tantissime fragilità ci sono ragazzini
che restano chiusi in casa per mesi ci
sono ragazzi che hanno problemi con il
cibo ci sono
ragazzi che si tagliano che si bruciano
quindicenni che prendono psicofarmaci e
che non riescono più ad uscirne Allora
io credo che sia un nostro dovere di
adulti e di essere responsabili quello
di cercare una chiave e non a caso io ho
messo una chiave musicale perché la
musica è sempre uno strumento che io
utilizzo per provare ad infilarmi dentro
agli esoscheletri e a trovare qualche
cosa che possa essere usato da me e da
loro e quando ci riesco Credetemi è una
gioia
incommensurabile perché allora entro e
vado dentro
[Musica]
siete preparati Non lo so
chi è cringe se io provo a fare delle
domande ai ragazzi e sono davvero
disponibili ad ascoltare quello che loro
hanno da dire
Credetemi loro vi portano
perché
se educare deriva dal latino ex Duco
quindi portare fuori io ritengo che sia
fondamentale che noi invece da questi
ragazzi ci lasciamo condurre ci facciamo
portare dentro E vi assicuro il viaggio
che sono in grado di regalarci è
qualcosa di straordinario Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]